martin biron josée legault christian
dufour bonsoir bonsoir
je vous faire écouter ceux qui n'étaient
pas avec ton tout début du tout début
d'émission monsieur legault qui dit que
sa patience a des limites
ma patience a atteint sa limite c'est
important qu'on laisse nos enfants puis
les patients en paix et puis qu'on est
passé manifestants anti vaccins
laissez nos enfants tranquilles on ne
peut pas tolérer une situation où des
enfants sont prises en otage où il ya de
l'intimidation qui se fait près de 12
écoles je pense qu'on est dans ta des
risques de débordements les parents sont
inquiets ont tant de dissuader des
enfants de respecter des mesures
sanitaires c'est inadmissible et comme
on le fait dans le cas des cliniques
d'avortement c'est possible d'intervenir
spécifiquement sur ces situations là
pour que ça arrête on a le droit de
s'exprimer en société mais si clairement
dans le cadre de demain deux sujets ou
d'une manifestation ça pose un problème
de sécurité pour des citoyens
il faut que cette fois l'os encore de
l'ensemble des citoyens québécois et
pour ça il faut qu'on comprenne où ils
veulent à lille le présentement tout ce
qu'on a c'est le ministre qui court
après classant son produit j'ai besoin
de ton consentement quant à une demande
sur quoi ils prêts de le détailler donc
on veut on va faire les choses dans le
bon ordre qui on donnerait pas un chèque
en blanc contrairement aux trois autres
partis d'opposition au gouvernement pour
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils veulent
parce qu'on l'a entendu martine les
partis d'opposition sont d'accord dit
allons-y pour éviter de même des
débordements on a en tête des parents
qui de l'autre côté sera maudit contre
les manifestants place après dégénéré
alors est-ce que c'est régler
politiquement passé martin on a la
preuve à l'appui tout le monde mais je
pense que sur le fond je pense que tout
le monde est d'accord mais je pense que
tout le monde va vouloir voir aussi le
projet de loi et où il va avec ça il ya
aussi une somme de une joute politique
lac et qui se prépare l'un qui se
présentent devant nous c'est d'abord le
gouvernement veut pousser effectivement
les conservateurs d'éric duhaime dans
les câbles c'est à dire que s'il refuse
de donner son consentement
il y aura ça va être ça vole pour suivre
sa voie il semble être des munitions ça
va être un cadeau pour monsieur legault
tu vas pouvoir utiliser à nous et sommes
en campagne électorale en disant
regardez les conservateurs ce sont ceux
qui ont laissé ses militants à aller
manifester crier des bêtises aux enfants
deuxièmement monsieur legault a jugé
assez rapidement parce que les libéraux
étaient très avancées dans ce dossier là
il est en train de se faire damer le
pion par les terroristes qui revêt la
loi déjà hier elle est là et c'est ce
qu'elle a dit madame langlade était
prête ce matin et ce qui me fait dire ça
c'est que cet après-midi la période des
questions monsieur legault a pris une
question marois risque et ça c'est très
rare généralement le chef répond à des
chefs alors il veut assumer sa assuré
son leadership dans ce dossier là josé
et christian est ce que ça vous étonne
ou pas cet unanimisme presse candidat il
faut limiter leurs
appels à la permission de manifester
devant des écoles josé
non pas du tout bon premièrement parce
que c'est de l'intimidation il faut
aussi on ne vit pas dans la campagne
fédérale ou si des manifestants très
agressif le talonner justin trudeau
aussi pour les mêmes raisons et je pense
que les parlementaires comprennent qu'il
faut agir avant justement qu'il y est
grave on a vu aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être pas des manifestants mais il
ya une infirmière qui était tabassé à
sherbrooke par un homme qui était
mécontent qui qui prétendait que sa
femme avait été vacciné contre contre
son gré donc il ya une montée de colère
chez une petite partie de la population
mais si lors que ça peut dégénérer comme
vous disiez c'est bien tout à l'heure
donc non moi je suis pas étonné du tout
et et éric duhaime est claire samson la
seule conseils qu'on pourrait leur
donner c'est de
cesser de ces de se joindre au mouvement
parce que sinon ils vont perdre depuis
de crédibilité qui lui reste un beau
défi pour éric duhaime la wii parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya un consensus assez
rare sur le principe que des
manifestations anti l'accès non vraiment
pas leur place près des hôpitaux et des
écoles parce que ce sont des populations
vulnérables facilement et sida depuis un
tas d'autres endroits dans la ville où
les gens qui sont content de vaccins
peuvent manifester se dit moi j'avais
l'impression que la police disposait
déjà des moyens en fait pour gérer ça
pour contrôler ça mais ça ne semble pas
le cas donc on va voir la loi parce
qu'on touche quand même à quelque chose
d'important ne doit pas manifester aussi
ça allait vite aussi à rappeler que les
gens qui sont contre les vaccins et dont
le son le droit bell contre les vaccins
et qu'on est en étant près de décréter
systématiquement à paris au ski au
dessus dans le droit de 2,2 de
manifester ailleurs moi je trouve qu'ils
ont tort je trouve que c'est
complètement de proches se faire
vacciner mais ils ont le droit de le
faire et on oublie en 5
dans les rues à montréal mais devant une
école où on va vraiment
très fort dans la société ça va plus
loin que ça l'espèce d'agressivité à
l'égard destrier qui veulent pas se
faire vacciner et moi je veux leur
rappeler qu'il ya un côté qui peut
devenir au dessus de barils pour revenir
à eric tu veux c'est clair que pour éric
duhaime c'est un test très important
parce qu'il représente en fait ceux qui
ont des problèmes avec la façon de gérer
la crise interne du gouvernement legault
donc le stade où c'est vraiment délicat
et j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont se
radier en fait au consensus mais en
regardant ce que c'est précisément la
loi il fait bien de regarder ce prix
normal voilà il faut pas de chèque en
blanc au gouvernement syrien le pro de
manifester d'accord mais il y aura une
décision à prendre vite vite vite demain
qu'un rôles texte et choisir la voie qui
vaut choisir bon il ya des hôpitaux qui
sont bloqués rien à voir avec les
manifestants ça a à voir avec le manque
d'infirmières avec le manque de
personnel encore l'hôtel dieu chez vous
on a commencé l'émission martin qui dit
aux gens de parvenir à l'urgence il ya
eu avant les firmes n'ont rien d'une
plaie en abitibi ils ferment des
urgences lol la crise pris de l'ampleur
de ce manque de personnel c'est qu'en
grèce le demain martine la barre et au
jeu legault a dit on va tout faire est
ce que le plein est bien ficelé d'après
ce que vous en dit pas ce que ça peut
faire une différence bah écoutez c'est
ça va être politiquement périlleuse cet
exercice là parce que monsieur dubé a
laissé entendre que c'était une
opportunité cette pandémie là qu'on
était pour faire des choses qu'on
n'avait jamais fait mais réorganiser
le système ça va vouloir dire des
changements et des changements c'est pas
facile si on se fie à ce qui s'est passé
en abitibi on a vu qu'on a fermé par
exemple des petits clc pour envoyer les
infirmières les ressources dans des plus
gros dans mon à centraliser le sait les
ressources dans des dans différents
endroits alors comment est-ce que ça va
se passer sur le terrain comment est-ce
que les infirmières vont réagir parce
que ça veut dire du déplacement de
personnel est-ce qu'on va éliminer les
heures supplémentaires obligatoires
les attentes sont très élevées du côté
des infirmières mais c'est certain qu'on
ne fait pas d'omelette sans casser deux
fait j'ai l'impression que la douzaine
va y passer et que ça va être des gros
changements pour les infirmières et que
ces dix sites et les changements à
prendre de changer de l'hôpital séduire
ne faut pas les choquer la jauge est et
christian folly séduire les infirmières
faut qu'hervé pour qu'elle revienne josé
mais en fait il ya plusieurs corps de
métier d'un système de santé québécois
qui auraient besoin d'une grande
séduction l'a pas seulement les
infirmières mais elles sont cruciales en
effet
écouter ya tellement de problèmes on
sait même pas par où commencer on les
connaît depuis des années dont justement
c'est ces conditions de travail qui
n'ont aucun bon sens dont le dans le
matin obligatoire qui fait que ya eu un
exode sur le tard vers les agences
privées et comme le gouvernement à faire
avec les haches ans vivait ben si le
cercle est vicieux dans lequel les
gouvernements se sont enfermés depuis
plusieurs années donc oui il va falloir
en récupérer une partie mais ça veut
dire aussi qu'il va falloir commencer à
ce que le gouvernement a en tout cas
commencent à ceux utilisés moins que ces
agences privées là par définition donc
c'est cc sont tellement d'éléments et
bon jeu le ministre l'a senti tendu est
un homme courageux on le sait on attend
beaucoup de lui et ce qu'on espère
surtout c'est que s'il ya quelque chose
qui débloque de ce côté là de manière
aussi est ce que il pourrait appliquer
une recette
similaire justement pour d'autres
professions qui sont malmenés notre
système de santé et où justement il ya
des gens qui quittent et avec la
pandémie qui a été vraiment la goutte
qui a fait déborder pour beaucoup
beaucoup de monde des fois ça prend des
grosses crises christian pour trouver
des solutions qu'on nous ait pas
appliquée est ce que ça sera ça demain
vous croyez
ajouté le ministre christophe dubi
crédibilité certaine dans ce domaine ne
il le mit en fait en jeu pour ce qu'il
est dit qu'il y aurait pas de bris de
service des gens autour de moi m'ont dit
si monsieur je vais réussir à quelques
stades parce que quand même l'échéance
pour les infirmières qui ont ou les
verts de la santé qui sont pas vaccinés
qui vont devoir quitter cyrus en
quelques semaines à régler
à faire sourire un système exemple
depuis longtemps je pense que la crise
certains c'est un révélateur de ce fait
qu'un système de santé qui monopolisent
faut-il le rappeler 50% des ressources
du québec n'est pas fonctionnaire est
juste à crystal bearers faut juste à
cauville sahara et me dit quelque chose
c'est très difficile de réformer des
gens m'ont dit si monsieur dubé cabab
l'écouté pas de rue devrait démissionner
on en parle on parle et je ne crois pas
tout reste posé quelques problèmes ces
agences privées ses nouveaux occupants
fonctions ça nous met en face de ce
qu'on est nous les québécois moi je lui
dis je le redis j'aime pas sans le dire
mais quelque chose qui marche pas dans
nos systèmes démocratiques en
particulier dans le domaine de la santé
on est confronté à ça il est urgent
thème est donc je souhaite désespérément
que monsieur dubé et des informations
qui lui permettent de penser que oui il
repose forcément débris service même si
plusieurs personnes notamment les jeunes
josi way pour parce que les agendas fait
l'écho de chansons meilleur pour les
infirmières oui tout à fait pour avoir
analysé moi même le système de santé
sous toutes ses coutures depuis de
nombreuses années je sais très bien que
les agences privées sont un problème
parmi d'autres mais c'est un problème
important et l'appât et tous ces
problèmes là qui ont existé en amont qui
ont vraiment éclatée qui ont explosé
littéralement depuis le début de la
pandémie on souhaite le succès au menu
du bep et on souhaite et s'attaque
ensuite à la première ligne parce que si
les urgences continue à déborder au
québec on sait depuis très très enfin
c'est parce que justement on n'a pas
réussi les gouvernements pas réussi à
établir une première ligne solide et les
infirmières ont un rôle aussi a joué
dans l'établissement d'une première
ligne beaucoup plus et les dockers mais
faut dire aussi que monsieur dubé et
face à une machine qui est tout sauf
flexible prenez les conventions
collectives avec les infirmières qui ont
été réglés cet été on estime pour que
pour mettre l'ensemble des nouvelles
mesures en place il va falloir autour
d'un an pour appliquer les conventions
collectives c'est quand même elle mais
là on a comme pas le choix de ne pas
fermer un nombre qui grandit d'urgence
comme seule année sa pub on sale c'est
là on est dans le simple bon ça nous
avons juste et nécessaire
exactement on le souhaite demain on
verse je serai pas là demain mais je
vais regarder ça je vous regarder de
loin
élections fédérales
trois rivières ce qu on a le résultat
coudes et on a dit que sa lettre dans
quelques minutes à 16h50 bombe 3 s'est
réglé ce que si monsieur villemur le
blocus ou l'ancien maire conservateur
yves lévesque on ne le sait pas pour
l'instant à suivre mais je vais vous
faire entendre monsieur blanchet qui a
fait son sa première conférence de
presse post soirée électorale
la responsabilité d'obtenir des appuis
c'est celle du premier ministre c'est
pour la mienne c'est celle du premier
ministre de faire marcher son parlement
et il est dans une situation qui est
singulièrement avantageuses parce qu'il
ya trop timide en classe il suffit en
ayant des troubles soient d'accord avec
mulliez correct alors la responsabilité
de faire survivre le gouvernement
libéral de justin trudeau soyez assurés
que ça soit pas ma préoccupation
première
mais en dix ans
josé qu'il voulait quand même qu'ils
souhaitaient que ça dure un certain
temps comme on peut se retrouver en
campagne électorale bientôt médias trois
petits amis en pensant au npd aux
conservateurs bien sûr et à lui qui
peuvent en tout temps sauver le
gouvernement là tu as quel état d'esprit
ils savent à ottawa le chef du bloc jose
mais je pense qu il s'envola dans le
même état d'esprit que les autres chefs
de parti d'opposition c'est à dire que
personne au canada ne veut d'une
élection d'ici six mois
et donc lorsqu'il dit que la
responsabilité va être entre les mains
de justin trudeau la responsabilité va
être aussi entre les mains des chefs
d'opposition dont lui donc non je pense
qu'on s'en va vers un parlement qui va
être stable qui va être table
possiblement longtemps et malgré le fait
que ce soit un gouvernement minoritaire
justement à cause de toute la
controverse qui a entouré le
déclenchement de cette élection aussi
par monsieur trudeau et donc non je
pense que monsieur blanchet va devoir va
devoir collaborer lui aussi sortir de
position christian on verra s'il est
difficile de prévoir ce qui va vous y
danser danser situé sur le rond point
qu'on est obligé l'elysée moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié le taux de violence
comme ci est encore en campagne le
paragraphe moynier pendant trois quatre
jours il connaît qu'une élection est des
états unis d'être positif c'est
peut-être un peu formel aux pillards
mais dont il n'a pas très connu mais on
n'était pas très bonne humeur
aujourd'hui beaucoup l'ont atteint ouah
c'est ça plus moi je trouve que le droit
ne bouge trouve pas ça correct parce que
c'est un gros effort une érection du
monde a travaillé tout le monde est à
coup de chaud le combat là on vient
d'avoir un nouveau gouvernement
je pense que
il souhaitait gagner quelque chose en
fait les 40e c'est quand même pas
innocent le 40e cv mis cette barre là il
y aurait eu la majorité des sièges au
québec le bloc depuis sa création
jusqu'à la vague orange en 2011 a
toujours eu la majorité des sièges au
québec alors s'il y avait réussi à voir
ses 40 sièges là ça aurait été une
victoire personnelle importante et il ne
le peut pas obtenu je pense que sur la
balance du pouvoir le devoir le npd
quand même là il se retrouve dans une
situation où il s'est carrément un statu
quo et le bloc n'aura pas plus
d'importance monsieur legault fera pas
affaire avec yves françois blanchet se
sont pas des amis ils se connaissent et
se respectent mais monsieur legault va
transiger directement avec justin
trudeau même coin ça sera peut-être au
chat noir de la friture sur la ligne le
caucus québécois des libéraux fédéraux
est en furie dame en compte monsieur
lebon pour les raisons qu'on connaît ce
sera à voir la suite des choses les
premiers résultats on encore du temps
oui
oui voit peut-être là-dessus a plus haut
comment voyez la suite des choses qui me
choquent québec actuellement à québec
est actuellement et puis je pense au
3éme n'est pas ce qui me semble que si
quelque chose qui est en danger par les
beaux projets de monsieur legault ccc le
royaume n'est active un qui était
partant pour une partie importante de la
population il ya des méchants plan qui
pense mais je pense que martin en
apparence parce que moi je peux pas pas
joué par expert sur la situation au
tibet région de québec d mais j'attends
qu'ils ont peut-être qu'au fond ça
ferait peut-être sur ce niveau là faire
de françois legault en fait que le
troisième ligne ne se réalise pas parce
que le fédéral est pas du tout intéressé
à aider mais moi si jamais des fédéraux
veulent se venger nous sommes plus là
c'est parce que josé williams tension
dans l'air disons
oui tout à fait normal je voulais la
sortie de monsieur legault en faveur des
bleus conservateur s'était quand même
fort de café donc oui et c'était très
risqué parce que même lorsque monsieur
ne vous le fais on voyait bien que
ce qui était le plus probable c'est
peut-être un gouvernement libéral
minoritaire donc c'est sûr qu'il va y
avoir des initiés c'est sûr qu'il va y
avoir des dépôts à réparer c'est clair
mais bon je pense que les choses vont
finir par dépasser mais le gross si les
transferts
cédait les exigences de toutes les
provinces pas juste le québec merci à
vous tous khaled soirée à très bientôt
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit